(light whimsical music)
- [Narrator] The Ultra 6633 is
a 352 mile-long race
across the Arctic.
It's cold.
- [Racer] It didn't
really get above minus 45.
- [Narrator] It's long.
- [Racer] I think that took me 150 hours.
- [Narrator] And most
people, don't finish it.
- [Racer] It's cold!
- [Narrator] This is Dave Berridge.
He lives on the Isle of Wight.
- [Dave] It's a small island
off the south coast of England.
- [Narrator] And last year,
he won the Ultra 6633.
So, I'm talking to him
about what it feels like
to race across the Arctic.
- Come back.
A typical marathon is 26.2 miles long.
So, this is like 14 of them, back-to-back.
(somber piano music)
The distance is isolating.
- [Dave] You're on your
own for like two days
at a time.
- [Narrator] And with negative
45 degree temperatures,
it feels even longer.
- [Dave] Everything out there is big.
There's just nothing to gage distance by.
There's nothing to judge anything by.
You can see nothing but white.
So, you start to think, on less sleep,
am I dreaming this?
Am I actually moving?
It's like being in a painting.
- [Narrator] It took Dave
six days to finish the race,
and he only slept a total of 10 hours.
"It's that exhaustion," he says,
"that causes you to lose your mind."
(light eerie music)
- [Dave] Your mind just
starts imagining all sorts.
I've went through an avenue of trees
and I thought I was going
through a disco party,
and every time I approached somebody,
they stopped talking
and just looked at me.
- [Narrator] But, you can't stop.
- [Dave] You've got to keep moving.
You think, "What on earth
is that coming towards me?"
And, you know, within two
minutes you're shivering.
You shouldn't have stopped
to look at something
that's not there.
(light pulsating music)
I achieved what I wanted to achieve,
and I finished it, and I'm very grateful
and very lucky to have finished it.
Out of all the races I've done,
it's one of the most mentally
challenging races out there,
and it's probably the race
that commands the most respect.
Anybody who finishes that will...
Well, I would say,
they've got my admiration.
(slow eerie music)